Toronto po workshops uh second
session we started out with some more
plane control exercises this time the
saloon
doors this exercise you can do in any of
the timing and Direction
moves we
do together Time same direction need
spot time off the direction
there you get comfortable with all those
and if that's not enough for you you
want to keep pushing this sort of
exploration you can also play with uh
different things like maybe one bends
horizontally while one bends
vertically and then keeping that going
open this
up so basically just take the concept
and play with it in each position as you
get comfortable being able to control
how you've been your SL door planes
around will give you a lot more control
and awareness in those positions
uh then we talked about butterflies and
how butterflies essentially are like a
mirror reflection of each other a
butterfly like this is basically just
the
same that me standing next to a
mirror reflecting that PO one Po and
twoo with a together time butterfly the
mirror is a vertical line that I'm
tracing
down with a split time butterfly but
it's a horizontal line that I'm tracing
along almost like maybe my poy is
spinning over a reflecting pond that's
not so much that I'm focusing on what
Rhythm it is I'm more focusing on always
drawing my poy along that mirror line no
matter where I want to put the mirror
line so now this is quarter time for
instance but I don't have to think about
it being quarter time I just have to
think about my mirror line being at a
45° angle so we could we could start out
in together time and gradually shift
where that line is
going and go through an entire range of
motion shifting your mirror line which
is of course inadvertently Shifting the
Poise timing through a variety of
different esoteric timings that you
don't even want to think about
practicing but that you get for free
just by moving where you pulse your
pulse along your ear
that last exercise led us to uh some
more body and plain awareness exercise
which is to be able to keep your PO on
one
plane while turning your
body reorienting your body through an
entire 360° turn with the Poise staying
on one plane the easiest way to do that
is just to use a wall is to touch your
hands the
wall and go through your quarter
turns always touching the wall once you
feel comfortable with that you can
practice just dangling your PO through
those quarter turn
presents paying particular attention to
how your arm and po create a frame or
Archway for your head can't be here I
have to allow my arm to reach all the
way over my head in a comfortable
position now once you get comfortable
with that if you start speeding up you
actually get some sort of fun pendulum
moves for free out of this practice and
eventually once you're really
comfortable with that you can you can
start spinning and playing
with keeping that going
flowers and eventually
maybe anti spin flowers we took a moment
to look at how to
spin split time butterfly in this
position one of the key things to that
position is instead of letting one hand
be under this shoulder and one over that
shoulder to bring both hands into the
center line of your body if your hands
are on the center line of your body you
can get a really nice split time
reflection sort of thing lining up here
but if I separate them apart the effect
gets lost this doesn't really look lined
up this does this same principle of
lining your hands up on the center line
of your body applies to pendulum
practice it applies to spinning in Split
Time same
direction this position also happens to
be one of the position
and split time opposite
arms so then we we covered some of the
finer points of moving your arms like
this so you want to focus on four four
Focus points one up one down one left
one
right and you really want to rely on
your torso turning
in order to get your arms to where they
need to be so I'm not focusing so much
on moving my arms I'm more focusing on
turning my body and just letting my arms
close and be on the horizon and then
opening my arms as I turn my body so
that they get back to that center line
in front of me turn the body they close
the Horizon turn the body and they open
from The Horizon and ideally at any
point in
time my hands are always one on top of
the other so that at any point in time
moving around like this I could stop and
drop something from the top to the
bottom and fall straight into alignment
with that other hand